[موسيقى]
اسرتنا
في منزلي انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
من بالباب
وبجسمي صوف شكل به يبدو مالوف وهنا
بالمزرعه اطوف اهلا بك اهلا يا خروف اهلا
يا اغلى الاحباب هيا اسمع مئمتك وسنفتح في
الحال الباب اليوم
اذهب اذهب يا كذاب ما دامت ماما بالخارج
لن ندخل ابدا
[موسيقى]
لننزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب في منزل
انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب
من بالباب بلطافه جئت احييكم اشهى البان
اعطيكم بالطاقه دوما تغنيكم اهلا اهلا يا
بقره اهلا يا اغلى الاحباب هيا نسمع صوت
خوالك وسنفتح في الحال الباب
هذا ليس بصوت البقره اذهب اذهب يا كذاب ما
دامت ماما بالخارج لن ندخل ابدا اغراض
انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في منزل انثى
السنجاب دق دق الباب
من بالباب النمر لكني اليفه في قفز حركات
خفيفه وانا مع الانسان لطيفا
في الحال الباب
هذا ليس بصوت القطه اذهب اذهب يا كذاب ما
دامت ماما بالخارج لن يا ابت
[تصفيق]
في منزل انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
من الباب امشي تتبعني صيصاني دوما اغمرهم
بحلالي في الخم لنا عيش الهاني اهلا اهلا
يا دجاجه اهلا يا اغلى الاحباب هيا نسمع
صوت نقيقك وسنفتح في الحال الباب
هذا ليس بصوت دجاجه اذهب اذهب يا كذاب ما
دامت ماما بالخارج لن ندخل ابدا اغراب
في منزل انثى السنجاب دقه دق الباب في
منزل انثى السنجاب دق دق الباب
قدوتكم في الوفاء احرسكم من الاعداء
افتحوا صاحبكم قد جاء اهلا اهلا يا ثعلب
اهلا يا كذاب لن تثبت هذه المره وستاخذ
اقصى العقاب
[تصفيق]
السنجاب دق دق الباب